now of course there is another liberal
out there an old school liberal who gets
it on one day then doesn't get it the
next day and seemingly uh makes some
sense and then makes no sense uh we've
talked about him a lot and i've got a
video here of him uh getting it and also
kind of not getting it
bill maher ladies and gentlemen the
argument to me is like has twitter
failed
in setting himself up in the past as the
judge of what can go out there and i
would say yes
you have you failed
when you threw the new york post off of
twitter
for talking about hunter biden's emails
and it turned out that was a real story
right you failed
when you said we couldn't read about
whether
covet had come from a lab
you failed
did you read about this babylon bead you
know what the babylon bee is
i didn't know this no it's like the
christian version of the onion
because everyone needs that
well some people do i thought that was
not all you and me okay it says your
trusted source for christian news and
satire i didn't know it was such a
biggest christian satire
i thought the religion itself was satire
that's me
i'm not everybody
okay
i'm not everybody have a little humility
great so listen to this they got flagged
for
they posted a funny video this is funny
to them okay
sensitive content twitter said in the
video they were making fun of twitter
for being too sensitive this is so
through the looking glass and here's
what happens in the video this woman who
going into the twitter building this is
you know parody this is what people do
on television have done forever
okay she's complaining to hr about how
sensitive twitter is and the guy shows
her an inkblot and she keeps seeing
hitler in all the inkblots
okay then she runs screaming out of the
building because she's
this is sad this is well within what
satire has always been
and the fact that they flagged us for
being insensitive shows their complete
lack of self-awareness about what their
own problem is if that's where the line
is you have failed twitter you do need a
new show
all right so bill moore
once again you pretty much get it now
he's also showing that he doesn't get it
he didn't even know what babylon b was
until they presented him with that
segment so it sure it sort of shows you
that he's out of touch of what actually
is kind of funny right now and relevant
and edgy and everything else but he does
something really nice there uh when the
other guy the msnbc guy what's that ali
velshi when he's like ah who needs it
like who needs christian satire and bill
maher even though he has spent an entire
career making fun of christianity and
making fun of organized religion he says
not everybody is me have a little bit of
humility that actually is a really nice
moment that's actually a really human
moment for bill maher so credit where
credit is due for sure and then of
course credit where credit is due which
is that he's defending satire now
unfortunately he hasn't been screaming
about all of the other censorship that
twitter has been doing for years but
again
i i suppose at this point the five last
remaining good liberals are just slow
motion conservatives that's what they
are and i guess we just have to take it
that's okay and maybe they'll fully get
there uh you know my feelings on all of
that